hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 4 video
lots of exciting stuff to talk about if
you like the show did everything short
of screaming in confirming one of the
biggest fan theories from the books so
we'll talk about all that stuff and new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video just
careful for spoilers as we get started
so this is gonna be top 7 moments just
because there was a whole lot of extra
stuff in this episode starting with
number 7 Jorah is taking Tyrion to
Daenerys this is right out of the book
so it wasn't a huge surprise the tease
was in the previous episode that he was
taking him to the Queen
Tyrion initially thought that it was his
sister but then he remembers who Jorah
is and that he had been informing Varys
in the small Council on Daenerys in the
earlier seasons remind me how you were
serving her inside a brothel but when
you think about it if he'd been working
for Varys the whole time in Varys had
secretly been part of the Targaryen
restoration maybe in spying on Daenerys
he was inadvertently helping her or at
least helping Varys make decisions based
on where she was at that's just a theory
if you take it in the literal context
yes he was a traitor to her initially
it's just that Robert was the one that
was calling all the shots he's like I
want to spy on Daenerys right now I want
to murder her Varys as master of
whisperers was responsible for hiring
Jorah I know everyone's wondering where
Varys is now we'll probably find out
next week he'll probably be back on to
number 6 Cersei reinstates the faith
militant and they arrest Loras for being
gay my favorite quote from the the
Cersei scenes this week there's a sinner
our very midst shielded by gold and
privilege she was talking about Loras
the double meaning in you know kind of
the look in the high sparrows eyes are
that Cersei is a sinner shielded by gold
and privilege may they all be judged
justly right now though it's only gone
as far as Loras and as we can see from
Margaery being so pissed Tommen isn't
able to do about it they just want
to put tom and forward as an ineffectual
leader he's a little boys so you can't
be too mad at him the show aged him up
quite a bit he almost looks like a
teenager in the books he is way younger
he's still a toddler
he's like a pudgy little kid the
downside is is that last week when they
had sex that's probably gonna be the
last that you see that for a long time
there's no way that Margaery is gonna
give it up while Loras is still in
Chains for those that are wondering he's
actually being held at bay lor Sept
souks
to see a trial type situation you know
in a twist of what happened to Tyrion
last year he was put on trial and got
steamrolled by the justice system now
thanks to Cersei there's a new lawman in
town and he's gonna steamroll anyone he
thinks is committing sin I'm kind of
diggin badass Lancel too he is way
better now than he was in season one
that's the seven-pointed star that's the
symbol of the church that are carving
into their foreheads eventually they're
probably gonna find out that Tommen is
also the son of twincest if you could
hear in that background shot in the
crowd shot when he went to the Sept they
were screaming bastard at him he seemed
a little confused like he didn't totally
understand what was going on but that's
gonna come back that's just like a hint
of things to come on to number five
Jaime and Bronn arrive at Dorne so just
a reminder of what they're doing is
they're trying to infiltrate the water
gardens to get Myrcella out they just
want to get her and come back to King's
Landing Jaime
unlike the sand snakes doesn't want to
start a war like an all-out war with
Dorne that's why it's only the two of
them Jaime and Bronn are like the new
Jaime and Brienne just absolute comedic
relief along with some really good
action scenes they even gave a shout-out
to Tarth as they were passing by turns
out it is not full of sapphires as Jaime
said they're just a bunch of really good
one-liner moments but I love the Jaime
is now using his hand as a defensive
device although was totally on accident
and he wants to die in the arms of the
woman he loves yes I do think he's
talking about Brienne even if he's not
willing to admit it out loud I do think
there's still a part of him that loves
Cersei just not in the way that he loved
her in the past I think he feels more of
an obligation to Cersei because she's
family because she's the mother of his
children and he's gone into like full-on
dad mode it has to be me I have to be
the one that rescues her so in addition
to waiting for like an all-out Jaime and
Brienne love scene now we need to wait
for a scene when Jaime openly tells one
of his children I am your father on to
number four meet the sand snakes this is
teeing up the Aryan Martell plot from
the books starting a war with King's
Landing whether or not they're
successful remains to be seen because
Duran Martell as they said wants to keep
the peace he has his own plan though do
you know just because they say he wants
peace doesn't mean that he isn't gonna
do anything about oberyn's death for now
though we just have to wait for a
potential meeting between Jaime and
Bronn in the
and snakes I'll add a link in the
description for the sand snakes video I
just did it just explains some of the
differences between the show in the
books this episode was really just the
first introduction to them so it's gonna
be a few more episodes before we see
what their characters are like on the
show on to number three
Melisandre tries to make a shadow baby
with Jon Snow there is great power in
you you resisted that's your mistake
power to make life power to create
shadows don't you just wonder how
powerful a Jon Snow shadow baby would be
there really is no benchmark for stuff
like that you have to assume that the
more powerful the blood the more
powerful whatever Melisandre conjures up
ends up being I guess it depends on how
powerful you think Jon Snow's blood is
versus Stannis that's an argument
that'll have to wait till after like the
final season for right now the show is
positioning both Stannis and Jon Snow as
heroes that was with that whole Shireen
scene with Stannis was about showing
that he's a very caring person in his
own cold way but all of this Melisandre
making sex eyes at Jon Snow is starting
to make a little more sense given the
context of some of the other scenes that
have to do with his parentage kant's
number two the show officially starts
pushing R + L equals J something you
probably expected this to come at a
certain point some of you might have
pooped your pants some price still don't
believe it just taking the show at its
word assuming Littlefinger was not lying
and sir Barristan Selmy is not lying and
I definitely don't think he was lying
there trying to position Rhaegar
Targaryen as a nice person who was in
love with Lyanna Stark how many tens of
thousands had to die because he chose
your aunt the crown of roses blue is
frost also ties in with a really big
prophecy from the show Rhaegar Targaryen
was obsessive about the prophecy that
prince who was promised that's why
everyone thinks that that is Jon Snow
he's like the secret prince that was
promised it's just that the prophecy
describes a blue rose growing in a wall
of ice so you have Jon Snow the blue
rose that was born of Lyanna stark up at
a wall of ice you know as in the wall
literally Dan and Dave aren't really big
on doing prophecies on the TV show they
did kind of do Maggie the frog which is
a prophecy but I don't think that
they're gonna get too crazy with that
stuff in the future hopefully we'll just
start to see more clues like more
characters start to point evidence at
the R + L equals J theory
right now the best evidence is what sir
Barristan Selmy said and what
Littlefinger said but the tourney at
Harrenhal is a really famous event
rhaegar targaryen really great gesture
won the tournament crowned Lyanna stark
instead of his wife Elia Martell Duran
and oberyn's sister causing everyone to
lose their including Robert
Baratheon who Lyanna Stark was promised
to and just to reiterate Robert's
rebellion didn't start because Rhaegar
Targaryen absconded with Lyanna stark it
started because the Mad King was
executing a bunch of nobles and their
sons but unto them my number one WTF
moment grey worm and Barristan Selmy
look like they're dead the sons of the
harpy lay a trap for the unsullied and
grey worm and Barristan Selmy kind of
get caught up in it ever since that
moment when Barristan Selmy left King's
Landing and said I could cut through all
of you like a carving knife through cake
they had to show off some of his skills
he's a really old person so if he's this
good now imagine how good he was in his
prime I also saw a lot of you guys
complaining on Twitter that gray worms
seem like he went down too easy they
just they want you to wonder whether or
not they're gonna survive there is a
promo for next week's episode
just because it's kind of spoilery it
kind of answers some of those questions
I won't talk about it here but if you
guys have seen it just use spoiler tags
here's my big question for you guys you
know what was your favorite moment from
the episode and do you feel like based
on the evidence presented in this
episode R + L equals J during the scene
where Barristan was explaining Rhaegar
singing to Daenerys they also casually
dismissed the threat of his door so I
feel like that's also kind of a warning
bell that he is associated with the sons
of the harpy whether or not he's
actually leading them remains to be seen
unless they roll out some other big bad
I feel like he is the one calling the
shots so much great stuff in this
episode Sansa also gonna have some
really interesting times while
Littlefinger is gone I'll be a married
woman by the time you get back the big
question with her storyline is what is
she going to do to try and outmaneuver
Roose Bolton and Ramsay Bolton if you're
a little confused about Littlefinger's
grand scheme here in the last episode he
was talking to Roose Bolton about
forming an alliance against King's
Landing but now in the crypts he was
talking to Sansa about forming an
alliance with Stannis who was going to
try and get rid of Roose Bolton add to
that that Cersei is calling him to
King's Landing
she still thinks of him as an ally so
right now Littlefinger has like a giant
list of opponents that he's all trying
to form alliances with at the same time
because the shows trying to present
Stannis as a hero I feel like he's the
one that you would want it back the good
guys don't always win on Game of Thrones
so it remains to be seen you can let me
know you know which group do you think
is gonna walk away from that big fight
do you think that Roose Bolton is gonna
be left standing or do you think that
Stannis is gonna steamroll him King's
Landing has its own internal problems
it's not going anywhere anytime soon no
nobody is marching on King's Landing
before the end of the season just a
quick reminder on the giveaway I'm gonna
announce the winner of that during the
Q&A tomorrow so just look out for that
in the meantime you can click here to
learn all about the sand snakes and you
can click here for last week's episode
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]